[Musik]
hey leute wir machen heute einen
beliebten kuchen ich sag beliebt ist
sehen weil ich bin mir sicher wenn ihr
diesen kuchen nach maasholm den
streuselkuchen mit marzipan
wenn es also ein kuchen der bei euch
beliebt ist weil ihr den zur kita
mitbringen werde zur schule zu
kuchenbuffets also ich bin fast schon
sicher dass es so sein wird weil diese
kulisse streuselkuchen die zwar als
trockenen kuchen gelten aber trotzdem
total lecker sind die sind einfach total
beliebt bei solchen anlässen oder auch
wenn ihr einfach mal so ein kuchen
genießen möchte mit euren bekannten
verwandten etc
ich glaube ich gar nicht lange drum
herum ich habe hier zutaten stehen und
damit machen wir jetzt zuallererst
unseren wirkt und dafür benötigen wir
die klassischen zutaten überhaupt also
mehl 1 1 und habe ich hier natürlich
zucker für süße und für den extra kick
nach vanille extrakt und zimmer warme
butter und ich gebe alles in eine
schüssel und vertrete das mit den händen
[Musik]
der mittag isst zusammen knetet und
eigentlich macht man ermöglicht mit
kalter butter und den steffi
geschnittener butter aber ich hoffe dann
immer so trick 17 und nimm einfach immer
warme butter und werde jetzt den boden
einer springform auskleiden und das
ganze dann für 20 minuten in den
kühlschrank geben damit es richtig schön
aushärtet eine springform hat irgendwie
ein durchmesser von 26 cm genau das
wollte ich nämlich gerade sagen stellt
den teig noch mit einer gabel heim wir
wollen dass der schöne möbel wird und
nicht hoch geht man backen
zur deckung des für 20 minuten in den
kühlschrank zum fest werden und dann
könnt ihr auf den ofen schon mal
vorheizen auf 180 grad ober und
unterhitze und wir kümmern uns zu lange
um die streusel für die streusel nehmen
wir mehr dann wahlweise zimt oder
vanille extrakt sie habe ich noch etwas
zucker und wieder zimmer warme butter
und auch wie gerade gehen wir jetzt
wieder alle zutaten in meinem schüssel
und seid nicht doof und einfach die
gleiche schüsse und dann spart natürlich
eine schüssel zum spielen du bist weil
ich sie hasse ich hasse spielen ich bin
ganz ehrlich ich liebe meine küche und
alles drumherum aber das spielen hat
sich einfach
[Musik]
sondern jetzt auch wieder alles
miteinander verkneten mit den händen so
das rezept gefällt mir echt gut weil
erstens es geht schnell zwei und sie
braucht keine maschinen und ich weiß
nicht jeder hat eine maschine zu hause
und drittens das geniale ist dieser
kuchen schmecken besser je länger er
steht das heißt ihr könnt ihr zum
beispiel montags backen und mittwoch
essen und damit schmeckt der noch besser
weil er schön durchzieht den kann
richtig gut vorbereiten
das sind die streusel und die kommen
jetzt auch erstmal zur seite weil die
brauchen wir nämlich später erst diesmal
packen wir nämlich den boden vor
und dann geben wir diese zwei zutaten
auf dem boden und dann die streusel und
die zwei zutaten von denen ich quatsche
sind einmal sauerkirschen aus dem glas
die last sie bitte ganz gut abtropfen
und marzipan hier habe ich
marzipanrohmasse das schneiden jetzt
ganz einfach in dünne scheiben und dann
wäre die vorarbeit auch erledigt
[Musik]
so hier ist alles vorbereitet der boden
ist kühl die 20 minuten im kühlschrank
syndrom und der kommt jetzt für zwölf
minuten in den backofen dann hole ich
ihn raus und dann zeige ich euch hier
das ganze belegen so die zwölf minuten
im backofen sind um der teig es
vorgemacht nun nehmt euch den ofen hat
verbrennt euch nicht und notfalls auch
noch unterlage falls die arbeitsfläche
mit hitzebeständig ist und jetzt gehen
wir erst den marzipan in scheiben drauf
dann die kirschen und dann die streusel
und dann wird es fertig gebacken
[Musik]
so und jetzt wird der kuchen für weitere
25 minuten bei gleicher temperatur zu
ende gebacken und es dann auch schon
fertig und nach dem backen könnt ihr das
entweder waren genießen mit einer kugel
eis oder abgekühlt mit sahne oder auch
einfach nur puderzucker oder ohne alles
also haben so viele möglichkeiten
und wenn das rezept nicht beliebig wird
dann weiß ich auch nicht weiter
also wollen sie schon beliebter hamza
und das geniale ist der hammer
das ist meine freundin gegessen anheim
zu vergessen falls fettnäpfchen getreten
egal dafür probiert haben sagt gleich
ich glaube die reaktionen sind alle die
uns auf instagram folgen falls ihr das
nicht mache dann unbedingt nachholen und
was ihr euch unbedingt noch sagen wollte
wenn es wirklich wenn ihr zu rebellisch
soll ich es probieren oder soll ich
nicht
die marzipan schicht vereint sich mit
den krümeln das aroma verteilt sich auf
den ganzen kunst ja es war auf jeden
fall also müsst unbedingt nachmachen
schaut in die video beschreibung für die
genauen mengenangaben haben sie nicht
verabschieden und setzt euch und sagen
das ist mein job description schließt
[Musik]